how the hell did that happen how did I
just walk away from that somebody your
distance from me
trying to blow my head off a mist
with Six Bullets
you didn't get a second chance that's
for sure
[Music]
hello and welcome to extraordinary lives
the podcast from Lab Bible in this
episode we're joined by Billy Billingham
great to have you here Billy and it's
great to be here thank you could you
give us a brief introduction to who you
are and what you're known for yes only
um I'm Mark Billy billing I'm better
known as Billy I grew up in the West
Midlands in the early 60s 70s
um went a little bit Rogue as a kid
getting in a lot of trouble
found sort of Direction with the
military I joined the military at the
age of 17 and a half in 1983 during the
parachute regiment
um
were served in Belize initially and then
all over the world with the partnership
regimen for nine years including three
operational tours including Northern
Ireland
um from there decided I want to go to
the best place I could and that was the
SAS I joined the SAS in 92.
stepped out and the first job we got
insecurity was head of security for a
number of a-lists celebrities including
Angeline Jolie Brad Pitt going from one
side of the camera guarding people to go
on the other side of the camera and get
involved in TV and up to date now I'm
working on a TV show called SAS who
dares wins and Special Forces toughest
test which is the same version but in
America I mean that felt like it was
about six lives he described that Billy
so we're inside yeah I'm excited about
getting into them but to go back to the
beginning you said they went a bit Rogue
as a kid so can we start there what was
childhood like for you right so I was
born in the West Midlands in a place
called Warsaw into an absolute great
family actually mum and dad
um two brothers older brother older
sister younger brother younger sister I
was the middle child my brothers and
sisters were great I just went rogue I
knew right from the early age out to
manipulate and get away with things and
I played the numbers game thinking you
know do 10 bad things if I can get get
caught by just one then I've done all
right and uh I really was I was um
that kid that you know when your mom
stands there and said oh he got him with
the wrong crowd yeah well I was the
wrong road and I knew it I knew what I
was doing in the area where I lived it
was all gangs it was it was a poor area
you know where it came from a poor
family not to say that's an excuse but
um so I started to get into gangs and
even at that young age then
I had my own little gang and I used to
steal Trilby hats right I don't know why
I did this it was crazy
sell them or just no I just collected
them because I thought it was cool I
wanted to try and make a name for myself
because as I looked at all the kids in
around my area
you know something they've been in uh
ball stool and all that sort of stuff
and I thought that was the right way to
go and have a name be the tough guy and
of course I was totally wrong
um so even from the age of nine I
started stealing these hats and me and
my two made so I used my mates would run
in front of the victim normally a 70
year old man distract him I'd run up his
back grab the hat and run off and then
one particular day this guy caught me
this old man chased me and caught me and
uh I just went into a panic I just went
straight into a boxing stance and my
teammates had legged it left me and the
old guy just stood up and says listen he
said there's something about you keep
the Hat come to my boxing gym and this
is very very true you gotta honestly
it's crazy so I threw the hat at him
grabs her hat and he lets me go but
before I went he says look the boxing
gym is here it was a pub downtown in
Warsaw called um
Rock City at least oh the digbeth at the
time
so I knew exactly what it was where my
dad drank right but something told me to
go there now this happened on a Sunday
afternoon in February it's now Monday
I'm nine o'clock sorry nine years old
I'm going to meet an old man that's
stolen from at the bottom of a at the
back of a pub who suppose he's gonna
teach me boxing but I went and it was
one of the best things I ever did it
became probably the second most
influential man in my life
so I went beyond this Pub I met this old
guy and um
absolutely breaking it thinking what am
I doing you know nine years old imagine
you letting your kid do that seven
o'clock at night Pitch Black in in
February so I'll go behind the pub
through the snow knock the door the old
guy calls me in so I'll go inside
and uh
I'm sure myself but I follow him and as
I go in I'm looking around I see all the
little kids around about my age all in
there doing boxing training so I've kind
of calmed down and I'm going to jump
forward a little bit here but the old
man basically took me to one side and he
says listen I want to teach you about
boxing
says okay he said boxing is not a sport
of brutality it's a poor man's game of
chess and I never forget these words and
this is very true right and he says look
it's about anticipating what's in front
of you having respect for what's in
front of you to win a fight you will win
it with your feet and your mind not your
hands and he says it's when the chips
are down it's about going that little
bit further don't give up now those
words I swear to you right I'm going to
jump forward 20 years I join the SAS
when I join the SAS in the middle of the
camp is a clock tower one of the sayings
in the SES is you have to beat the clock
which means if you don't beat the clock
your name goes on that toe it means
you're dead killed in action like a lot
of my friends are unfortunately
now at the bottom of the clock the last
line is always a little further
just like the old man had said to me
when I was nine years old and I've kept
that as my Mantra all through my life
amazing do you think he knew that about
the SAS no he had no idea mate I mean I
didn't even know I was nine years old it
would just happen to it was just a
saying and a phrase and it was really
like the airs on the back of my neck
still look when I read I went wow yeah
because I always remember those words
from nine years old you know and from
that age I started to go really Rogue I
was getting in a lot of trouble thinking
I was a tough guy I was getting brought
home every other weekend by the police
for whatever it was at the age of 11 I
had a criminal record so the boxing gym
didn't necessarily straight you
understand set you on the straight and
narrow
kind of put me on the straight tracks
for a while yeah it also taught me how
to fight which made it worse if I'm
honest but he gave me respect and he
gave me discipline and I was training on
a Monday and a Wednesday I think it was
so at least on those nights I was
staying out of trouble yeah but then
getting in trouble the rest of the time
you know but I knew what I was doing you
know when people say oh it's just a
child doesn't always say I knew what I
was doing
but what did you want what did why we
did I was looking for status right I was
looking to be like the hard guy in the
town you know I think that was it
um and then at the age of 11 like I said
I got a criminal record
um for abh gbh and whatever else that
was and then at the age of 13
um and in between this sorry I joined
the cadets this is my first insight into
anything to do with military
and I loved it
I loved the way I was being treated the
discipline of it you know if you just
did something wrong like in the
old-fashioned he was you got a clip
around there and put straight and I
liked it I enjoyed it but what I also
enjoyed was the fact that I was see
being taught how to read a map made
sense to me how to do first aid so
everybody's someone's life again it all
made sense to me all these things that I
was learning
you know made sense while I was in
school
crossing the t's dot in the eyes
learning it made no sense to me and I
was still going a bit wrong at the age
of 13.
I decided to glue the maths teacher Mr
Lynch to the chair sort of put glue on
his thinking always Big and of course I
get thrown out of school and expel from
school
at 13 yeah and like I said my dad was a
wonderful wonderful man but he worked
12-hour shifts he couldn't really
control me and when he came in after
doing 12 hour shifts mum went out doing
12 hours so it's all difficult and
anyway one was a parent anyway
you know it is difficult to control your
own kids you can like your kids can wrap
around your fingers that's what I was
like
and uh so yeah so I got expelled from
school I carried on doing the cadets I
carried on an unboxing I was getting in
and out of trouble
but I knew I wanted to join the military
I just knew it that's where I have to go
but now I know I couldn't join until I
was 16 because I had a criminal record
it finished at 16. ah I thought that
would be great I'll keep my nose clean
as best I can and I'm still getting in
trouble but I was getting clever at it I
weren't getting caught as much then the
age of 15 things went badly wrong I
ended up in a fight and uh with two guys
and I got stabbed I got stabbed in the
back Jesus how old were they about 17 18
I think for that age that's quite a
severe yeah eight little bit like I say
this is the world I was in yeah it was a
time of the skinheads and all this stuff
and although it had nothing to do with
that music music thing or it was just a
fight it ended up in a fight and I got
stabbed so what what happened like where
did that fight come from it was just
some falling out although I can't
remember why we had some falling out
over some gang issues or something and I
end up on the embankment Railway and
banking at the back of my house fighting
with the two there were brothers fight
with these two guys and while I'm
fighting with one it was kind of I was
pushing down the bank the other brother
came behind me and I thought he hit me
with a brick in the back and then all
lost all my wind and went light headed
fell to the ground they sort of legged
it and I ended up feeling around feeling
all the blood and realized I've been
stabbed God and I crawled back to my
house and I'll never forget it you know
that when you saw you've been kicked in
the nuts and you get that can't breathe
feeling I had it was like that pain and
I'm crawling back to the house and as
I'm crawling I could feel the blood all
running down my back and down back of my
legs and all on my hands not knowing how
bad I was
and I crawling over through the fence to
my house and I'll remember crawling
through the back door can see it right
now crawl through the back door and my
mum was like mopping the floor and she
turned around and just screamed
obviously you could see I was covered in
blood but at that stage I was going
through the door it was it felt nice I
was like I was floating basically I was
bleeding yeah the pain had gone and but
I can remember seeing my mum and then
the next thing I'd collapsed she covered
and got police got the ambulance and off
I went to hospital
and I was lucky very lucky but and I
recovered but I remember lying in
hospital saying to myself
if I get through this
I'm I'm staying out of trouble I am
doing everything I can to get into the
military and that's what I did I stayed
out of trouble what I didn't do what I
should have done has gone back to school
I didn't I ended up getting a job in a
factory in an electoral plating Factory
totally illegal 15 years old
and I worked on the night shift uh 12
hour shifts earning 80 pounds cash in
hand
and electroplating for anybody that
doesn't know what that is is um where
you take like rusty old metal and stuff
and you put it through a process of
caustic solder sulfuric acid and then
into zinc or Chrome and it comes out all
nice and shiny so I started working in
that and then on the night shift there
was only two of us on and it was about
two o'clock in the morning I had an
accident
basically the the older guy the adult
who was working the crane that picks up
all the work and puts it in these Vats
of acid and stuff went to the toilet and
I thought like I do I could do that so I
jump on the crane break it and panic a
little bit and figure [__] before he
gets back from the toilet I need to
[__] fix this so I jump up on top of
the um caustic solder right next to the
sulfuric sulfuric acid and I slip and as
I slip I went in just to just below my
knees
which for this day I don't know how they
all have been going because these vat is
six foot I shouldn't even beer I should
have dissolved I bounced with Agony
backwards and as I came out and sort of
landed on the floor the guy who was
working with come running back saw it up
and grabbed me round me to the top pull
my coveralls off rip my wellingtons off
turn the tap on and all the water ran
down my legs I can watch it watching it
and it just went in the layers of skin
the skin just dropped off
and he's like just blurred and bits and
it was stinking it was painful as [__]
and I thought [__] I'm gonna lose my
legs and in the Panic he grabs me
runs me to his personal car throws me in
the back and heads towards the hospital
can't wait for an ambulance but on the
way to the hospital
I was lying on his backseat like a
cricket rubbing my legs together
absolutely in agony you know
and all I could think about was [__]
how painful this is and I'm gonna lose
my legs and as I pull into the hospital
I remember I can see it right now
accidentally emerging I'm looking at it
and the pain went from my legs into my
heart and my head and I thought I've
just [__] up my whole life because I'm
now now 50 and a half 16 I'm just about
to join the military and I've kept
myself clean ish and now I've got this
injury and I thought that's ruined my
whole life I'm never going to go into
the military now because of these
injuries the injuries were quite bad and
he took nearly a year and a half to get
them fixed so I didn't get into the
military so while this was happening
every two weeks I had to go across to
Wolverhampton careers office to the
medical get them checked check him away
checking all these things before that
allow me to join the military so that's
what I did and eventually I ended up
joining uh the partnership regiment but
what's what's interesting there is like
it's amazing that you thought you were
about to lose your legs yeah and the
first thing you were thinking was I'm
not going to be able to join them like
where was this passion do you come from
a military family like where was the
passion for joining the military why was
it so strong at such you'd be very
honest with the passion was staying
alive right I knew because of the way I
was living what I was doing I'd have
ended up getting killed you know I look
back I've been back to the area where
most of my friends are either in jail
for uh for Life or Dead yeah and I was
going that way I never got into drugs
but I got into you know I was going
totally wrong and I knew the military
was saving grace I had to get into the
military and am I right in thinking that
you actually
you got quite good at boxing didn't you
do you not have to make a decision
between military and boxing yeah I did I
was I was boxing
um
really from the age of nine from the old
guy and then at the age of 11 he handed
me over to a proper club and I never
figured that was like a real horrible
moment for me I felt like
the block that I respected is has put me
in the right direction to a degree was
dumping me but actually wasn't it was
putting me in two because at the age of
11 You Can Box competition yeah so I
then went to a proper Boxing Club and
actually it was one of the best things I
did the boxing club was fantastic so I
stayed with them and you know I was
boxing pretty well and I was on the
verge of shoulder stay sort of staying
stay with the Midlands and go
professional boxing or do I join the
military but our kind of my heart was in
the military
so I think
the military side of it all this as
passionate as I was to be in it I don't
think my dad wanted me to be in it
wanting me out the Midlands he wanted me
to do something but it weren't until the
night before I joined the army that he
really let his fought out and I didn't
realize to later on why he did what he
did and basically to give me a kick up
the ass my dad wasn't one of these
cuddly lovey dads he was six foot
Bruiser but a great ringer still run our
family
and he almost did everything to put me
off it yeah even even to the point of
saying what happens if you go to
Northern Ireland I want to go to
Northern back in the day that's when it
was pretty much a hotbed yeah UK and on
in Ireland you know people getting blown
up and killed all over the place and uh
of course as soldier you want to make a
difference try and stop that and
be you know see how you reacted
and he says that's great what if you die
and you know I'm looking at my mom and
dad and they're just staring at me going
well I guess you better me Dad don't you
anyway yeah
I mean your mom we bury you
so you can imagine how I went to bed
that night thinking what the [__]
I thought was going to be proud of me of
leaving the Midlands got away from the
lifestyle of and the trouble had caused
for the family
and do this and I went to bed thinking
what the hell is going on
and I actually pretty damned well I know
what it was I know I didn't find out
till after he died unfortunately but it
was to put that rocket up my ass of you
never really did the emotional thing
with me the love he cuddly lovely sort
of stuff and uh he wanted to try that
everything he tried on me you know give
me a slap discipline in me never stopped
me doing what I want to do and getting
it getting into trouble
he tried this to say to when the chips
were down I was probably gonna throw my
hand and come out it was that in the
back of my mind to prove my dad wrong
and stay there and that's what he was so
that part so you get the parachute
regiment you said was the first place
you went now obviously to a young person
that's about to join the military I
think that what a lot of people would
think was the most important thing as
being tough and you must have been quite
tough at that point because you've been
boxing since you were nine you had this
incident with your legs that you'd sort
of push through recovered not giving up
once you got in there did you see
yourself as quite a tough guy at that
point were you thinking right I'll get
in here and I'll be like I'll be able to
smash this too well man that's a great
question no I didn't I forget that time
I realized bear in mind I'd never really
been out of Warsaw I was a tough kid
around Walsall who should have the
skills from Birmingham come over
Wolverhampton Coventry you know only got
in early got nasty you know getting
these scraps okay this is all right this
is what it is then when I joined the
parachute regiment at the age of 17 I um
I'll never forget it day one standing on
the square of seventy seven zero people
and looking down the line I'm still 17 I
was skinny as hell I think I weighed
about eight and a half nine stunks I've
been boxing for years
and as I look down the line they all
seem bigger and older than me you know
all the big blogs hairy chests tattoos
mustaches
Scotsman Welshman people I've never
really met before and I remember
thinking to myself what the f have I
done I have not got a clue I've been
gonna make this did you feel like a kid
among adult yeah I tell you I felt like
a a very small fish in a big pond yeah
okay and then stood in front of me was
one of the most respectful people I've
ever ever met was a Corporal my
instructor
I'll call him he um he had a fresh scar
right across his face being shot in the
face in the Falklands
and I never forgetting from his only
moments of speaking to us just thinking
well that's who I want to be right
respect that man you know even I was
proud I didn't even know him at this
stage I'm proud of who he is what he's
done because we knew what he'd done and
I just thought that's who I want to be
and I looked at these people again and
thought
unless they throw me out I ain't going
nowhere I'm going to give it everything
I've got to get through this and I had
no confidence you know I was the
skinniest the youngest
the gobbyist for a short while not for
long I'll tell you that and but as the
days and the weeks went by the lines got
bit smaller and smaller and the big guys
were all falling out and I was starting
to Growing concert so this is the
selection process yeah for anyone that's
listening that doesn't know can you
clarify what the parachute regiment does
yeah the parachute Regiment of the uh
infantry it's the Airborne Division or
or battalions of the Infantry it's
probably in fact it is it's without
shadowed out the best soldiers
in the British military other than
probably the SES and I wouldn't say the
SAS are better we're just parallel to
them we'll work at a different level
um it's a very very tough
um process and as I said 70 of us died
at that process only seven of us
finished God yeah that's the numbers
you're looking at how over how long six
months it's a six month course but
there's a part on it called P company
yeah just like the Marines have their 30
miler there that's everything this is
three days of ten tests free free tests
on each day except for the last day
which is four tests and it's like a 10
miler with uh you know 50 or 60 pound in
one hour and 10 or whatever it is I
can't remember they don't call me on the
numbers
um stretch erase log race it's
absolutely horrendous and I mean
terrific and I remember when I did it I
thought well I'm never doing this again
and on the log when you do the log race
which is normally if you fall off a log
that's it you're already automatically
fail right
um this is fall off it as in if you drop
the log yeah this is the log the log is
a telegraph ball basically right and the
six of you two at the front two at the
back two in the middle and it's your on
hands are looped into it with a rough
rope right and that weighs a ton when
when you're running with it and it's
about two mile race
and by the time we finish that I think
there's only three of us left on the log
and I was on the front and my arm was
like the like Stretch Armstrong by the
time I finished God I remember dragging
it over the line thinking oh that was
horrendous could hardly breathe but when
you're going through that selection
process as a young guy and you're seeing
these bigger guys from all over the
country dropping out was that making you
think God this is really hard or was
that making you think okay I'm still
here I'm still here they're gone now
it was it was a reality check of this is
odd this is horrendous but growing in
confidence believing in myself you know
I think I can do this
and when I did do it and past P coming
although there's enough there's two more
phases to it after P company peacock is
the hardest thing without Shadow of
Doubt physically anyway
and it's um you know people get to the
end
but it doesn't mean you've passed you
have to get have put in enough
performance given 100 to get you you
have to get at least eight points out of
ten on every event
now and they don't tell you if you've
done good enough or not so it's always
playing in your mind just the fact that
you're there at the end doesn't mean
you're gonna pass and I'll never forget
B there was we ended up in the
auditorium and
I think there's about 40 of us no 30 of
us started that by that stage you know
most of them are already gone 40 people
had already gone first of us that
started it and you go into this
Auditorium and the all the staff are at
the front and you just get your name
called out and it's like Smith
staff
fail
staff sits down and you're looking at
you again and then Smith just gone then
gone yeah and he just he was better than
me in your head and I never forget it
then my name gets called out stand up I
know you pass and it was like I'd won
the lottery
bearing in mind in school all I ever
heard was maths Billingham fail English
Billingham fail and then I just heard
this pass and it meant more to me than
anything in the world the fact that I
just passed I think I brought about six
foot after that
and I came out there thinking wow this
is unbelievable so yeah
they've failed they what happens to them
is they go they get back squatted they
go back and do the whole thing again or
they get out most of them get out
because you know that's enough but there
are some that go back and do it again
okay and then when we've got to the end
you know you do that then you go to
Wales uh you do these military exercises
which is pretty horrific you know and
again that was in like
freezing cold winter in the snow and the
ice for two and a half weeks then you do
you're parachuting down at prize Norton
which is kind of class as a holiday but
if get in front of an aircraft
[__] fully serviceable aircraft
parachute on your back you know it's a
holiday then that's what it is but for
me that was the first time I've even
been on a plane right so it was on new
experiences and never were you excited
by them were you like going this is
excited not intimidated I was
um frightened by it you know because
people get killed punishing
I don't know I've never even been on a
plane like I said the first day I get on
a plane I'm on this playing the C130 and
I'm looking and thinking they're saying
what I'd expected yeah there's wires
everywhere yeah Raw you know they take
off and then all of a sudden you know
you've got this thing on your back that
weighs almost the same way as you get
pulled to the door stick your head on
you're like
well next thing out and you're like out
you go
I'm falling through the sky I wonder
what the hell and then you're like as
soon as you feel that pull on your
shoulders after four seconds poof and
it's open you're like oh then you're a
king again am I right in thinking that
you ended up becoming the champion Cadet
I did the champion recruit like I said
there was seven of us finished at the
end and I was actually the champion
recruit and what does that mean does
that mean just to top it means the best
of all of the whole platoon that's
amazing well it was amazing but I mean
I'm not saying I'm any better than
anybody else but they just said I was I
didn't want the results they're all good
great people but for me
what an achievement yeah standing there
looking at my mom and dad and my old man
who actually didn't think I'd ever make
it
and I didn't tell him it was a temporary
group oh really and did they announce it
in front of them my mom absolutely
figuring oh you know she delighted my
dad's like
okay well done where's the bar and then
if we jump ahead a little bit so we're
so you've passed you've passed now yeah
you've got through you're selected yeah
what was your first what was it your
first tour like you know what was the
first experience of being sent somewhere
like well
right this is true as well right back in
the day then when I was in Depot you
used to have these pay phones you wanted
to pay phone and go so I then pass out
pass out means you've you've finished
your training
um I've been told I'm going to three
para Third Battalion the parachute
regiment there's three battalions one
part two paraphobra
and my uh troops uh platoon Sergeant who
was from free Prague was great because
you've gone to Central America so I hear
America I'm going to America Belize I
didn't even think about Belize I just
heard Central America so hi bro this is
true I run to the phone ring my mom up
and I go hey mum I've got a three para
she goes she didn't know what that meant
so it was great because well where's
that where are you going I went America
check Sun beer so wow what about America
when Belize she's like you clown Belize
is in the jungle I went oh she goes if
you'd have done your geography in school
you'd know where you're going yeah so I
haven't gone to America but so that's
where I ended up I ended up in in the
jungle of Belize and I must have been a
shark oh was it ever mate I've never
been in the jungle of course you know I
mean all I ever knew about the jungle is
what you see on Tarzan yeah so I thought
right okay here we go yeah and you go up
to the Battalion this was this is quite
a sad time in my life actually because I
went up to the Battalion and obviously
you know gonna leave for about two weeks
and he came back and the Battalion was
already out there so you go on to what
they call rear party where free parrow
normally live in all the shop there's
just a skeleton crew just keeping
security of the camp so we ended up
doing that for a week and I met a
wonderful wonderful guy there
called Benny
and um
it was the only real adult that spoke to
me
or us really nicely and obviously got
for training you have to be shouted
screamed out and pushed to the Limit
and you know you don't really get a
rapport relationship with these people
and then he was the first person and he
was a great guy he'd been to the fork
and he's done all this and he was he was
running the rare part and he sat us down
he goes right Lads listen to me when he
got to the Battalion this is what you
need to do keep your mouth shut you
ain't big guys he says listen and learn
follow the people out acquire not the
people that are screaming and shouting
because they've got nothing to teach you
and he was absolutely 100 right and he
actually said to us he says I'll see if
the last couple of months of the tour
anyway because I'm coming out finish the
tour off make some money and I'm getting
married and then I'm out the army
now bear in mind this is 1983 for the
beginning of 84. the Falklands has only
really just finished so everybody in the
Battalion really except for a couple of
terms before me had been to the Falkland
so these were no-nonsense people they'd
all been to war
so I'll get out and join the Battalion
and wow it was like I've never been away
from home I'm now the gobby newest
recruit not gobby anymore but the newest
recruit no one's really talking to me
and it was a real tough time
and then being put in The Jungle which
was I had romantic fantasies about what
the jungle might be like it was
horrendous
horrendous you know I was a new guy they
give you the biggest gun
the anti-tank weapon which you're never
going to use in the jungle anyway but
the mate you carry it you've got all
this weight all this water all this kit
and you're at the back of the patrol and
just following just trying to listen and
learn
and you the first couple of patrols out
there I was absolutely petrified I
remember day one getting off the
helicopter we've only gone about 20
meters into the trees put our burgers
and wait for the other cops to go let
everything settle then you start moving
tactically
I just put my hand in the side and
Bergen this tarantula runs up my hand
this is like on day one hour one of
being in the jungle God it's big Beastie
things running and it sat on the back of
my shoulder neck and I'm like froze to
death thinking so I'll just shoot myself
here
and the lads are just taking the person
laughing at me like you know I'm like
what the [__] somebody take the [__] off
and eventually some hardest Nails
blockers and sweeps you off with half my
head and off you go again and you know
this was my introduction to the Jungle
no one's I'm like what and at that point
are you like
like just to be a bit blunt about it
like you're not scared of being killed
as well yeah you are you're on at the
time I mean this is the first time I've
really cut carried live rounds yeah with
everybody else and the reason we're
doing that in 1984 there was still a
skirmish going on across the board of
Guatemala and um Belize itself so there
was we're border patrolling
and the reason they were doing that
mainly was because intimidation of the
local populace to scare them out to
either loot or steal or grow uh and
steal
um poppy poppy um plants and drugs and
also illegal logins so it was real now
there was a couple of skirmishes I put
it personally wasn't involved in any
where there were shootouts and kind of
people did get killed you know while
we're out there and yeah it was
dangerous so it was all this new world
to me grown men been to war carrying
live rounds now intimidated but
intimidated by the jungle taking a while
to fit into this group of people which
is probably rightly so you know so yeah
it was absolutely petrifying and
the lesson the guy Benny told me right
at the start was you know you get some
people want to Gob off and shout and you
think oh he's a tough guy I'll listen to
him then you find out later on absolute
idiot probably did nothing and the
quieter guys within the group who are
sort of gravitated towards were the
right ones who've done it been there and
taught me you know and it was he was a
wonderful wonderful time
and so the reason I mentioned Penny was
because
Paramount I'm 17 yeah you know I've seen
people have been around people that had
been killed growing up but not to this
extent and then I remember one night one
day was in uh at the
we came out the jungle we're at the base
camp
and all the alarms went off and normally
when the alarm alarms go off on the camp
there's a big problem
so I'm down by the rugby pitch and the
helicopter comes in the alarms have gone
off all the medical teams are still
doing nothing what the what's going on
here
and the helicopter comes in and lands
and they bring a body off
and it was Benny
and I was like
and I think I grew up again that day I
was like Jesus Christ this is real he
was gonna get married he was the one
who's he finished off and getting
married God bless him yeah so you know
it was an old
baptism of fire big learning people
we're not like maybe this is too much
for me no it just made me feel like you
know I'm here for the right reasons
nothing ever made me feel like I wanted
a goal you know even the artists of
times they had to they were going to
throw me out
you know I ain't going nowhere because I
need this where does that come from
because a lot of the people that we meet
who would have similar experiences to
you yeah or or the the sort of like
military that we meet the other people
would have had no choice but
people like yourself are willing to
volunteer to do that
where do you think that like what is
that mindset
it's just the one to do it and feeling
yeah you know I had a number of things
whizzing through my head one I want to
make a difference one I want to I want
to change my whole lifestyle instead of
being known as this idiot this little
scumbag that's causing trouble I want to
be respected so that was always there
I did love what I was doing I love the
challenges I love the fear of the
unknown I did you know you know the fact
seeing people die and think like that
could be me I kind of off my answers
that could be me they were offices no
it's not me it's not going to be me and
I always believe that and I've since
then I've been in some horrendous
situations where to this day I feel
don't know I've walked out of it so I
felt it was the right reason for
everything inside me said I want to be I
need to be it and I was enjoying it the
hardships you know I enjoyed it the
artists didn't I kind of was had a good
foundation from it from growing up you
know like I said we came from a very
poor family it was rough living I
freaking everything was gonna hand me
down I hardly had any shoes until I was
about 13. you know it was a tough old
time growing up it was
so he kind of sent me the right set but
I just wanted to be there because it's
an angel it wasn't for money certainly
wasn't for money because the money in
the army
okay terrible so do you think that do
you think that kind of like the mental
strengths do you think it's something
that's grown or do you think it you
start off with a wiring in a certain way
that sets you on the path where you can
develop into it I think yeah you are
born with a certain you know
strength of mind and then you just
develop it it's just believe in yourself
and
every situation I'm in either I'll say
to myself there's got to be a way around
this or through this yeah and there is
well there's proof I'm here [__] is
still here today doing talking so you
know it's just never giving up I just
don't give up you know and it's just
it's growing with me I don't like to
fail I don't get all you know I don't
have a teasy fit about failing I'll
learn from it I'll go okay up should I
do that again or maybe that was such a
bad mess I shouldn't do it again or if
it wasn't so bad I'll go and do it again
and hopefully get around it you know so
that's always been my mentality and I'd
say the the thing that you're you've
become a sort of household name for is
the SAS so yeah what was the point where
you've started looking at thinking about
joining the SAS and can you give people
who don't exactly know how it all works
an indication of how tough it is to join
the SAS yeah I can so basically I mean
you don't know a lot about it when you
join the military when you go into the
army Cruise no one talks about the SAS
right you know it's the SAS area what
they call a tier one group very very
small group of
special forces in UK there's only two
two special forces that's the SES and
the SBS right attached that we have
surveillance teams which but that's
always SAS SBS in America
virtually everyone's Special Forces
right they have a tier one special
forces which is Delta and seal term six
which is our equivalence
so you don't know anything about that
sort of stuff when you join the careers
you join the Army and all want to be
like everybody when you're first you're
on the Army be in the Army be in that
unit
then as you you sort of grow and go
through uh experience and time you learn
about the SAS because you always
crossing over room somewhere around the
globe you hear what they're doing
friends of mine before me had gone to
the SES
now I didn't really decide that's where
I wanted to go until about
seven years into my career good friends
of mine had gone and I knew they're
doing great stuff I bump into them once
a year somewhere having a beer then
everybody said what they did but I know
they're up to good stuff
and um
at the end of The Seven Year point I'd
been to Northern Ireland operational
tour of Cyprus I've been to Belize so
I'd seen some action I've done some
stuff
and I thought where do I go next I'll
tell you what it's like it's like
although I'm not saying parachute
regimens low down if you're in a
footballer you start off in a particular
team whoever the top team is that's
where you want to be right the premier
top of the Premier scene well that's the
same as the special forces the SES you
want to be and and now we'll tell you
this now that's not just in UK the SES
without Shadow doubt the best special
forces in the world really fact yeah we
you know most special forces we've ever
fought against or fought alongside I
don't know who the special forces are
like well it's true we are Shadow of
Doubt we are the best in the world fact
so
at some point you know most people go I
want to do that
it is in the rentals course we all know
that so the seven year point I put in my
papers because you have to volunteer
from the parachute regimen to go and do
sea selection I then got told I've got
to give another two years to the
parachute regiment as an instructor
down at the Depot which is where I went
through you know which is obviously a
great privilege to do that
so that's what I did and when I went
down to the depot
which is perfect for me you fit as a
fiddle you're running 210 miles a day
you're in the gym every day your
navigation skills are great your
soldering is great it costs you training
you're training the up-and-coming new
paratroopers
so that's what I did so when I went down
there I knew I got two years of of a
waiting time and preparing me to go on
selection so that's what I did and then
um so that's nine years of service yeah
so yeah so the end of the end of the 9
23 or 24 so it was still quite young
yeah still young yeah which is that was
the average age back then right joining
the parachute regiment
um
or 25 whatever you have to work the
numbers out but anyway so
yes that was really the average age sort
of between 24 and 27 to join the
parachute I told you on the SAS so I
decided then well I decided at the seven
year but that's where I want to go and
the nine year Point they'll let me go
and I joined the course uh first course
of 92. which was a winter course there's
two courses a year winter and a summer
course
I did the winter course which is the you
know a lot of people say it's harder
some people say summers are whatever I
would definitely say the winter one is
harder especially for navigation because
she can't see Jack over black mountains
down there in the snow whatever
so I did that course and I turned up and
I think it was 283 of us turned up
and you're all stood
on the Square Enix just like going back
nine years when I was a young kid and we
all do this she's like you know when you
go through a particular job you look at
everybody else and go wow he she looks
smarter than me he's got the kit it's
exactly I was doing again now I'm still
at the end of the line of 283 people
instead of 70 this time God he looks
bigger he looks fitter they look better
I'm thinking 283 yeah and I'm saying to
myself what the [__] am I doing yeah
again
same thing we in fact day two 80 of them
are gone because you do think all the
fan dance
which is that that is the the the filter
for anybody who really shouldn't it's a
fun dance it's a 24 plus kilometer race
let's just say off the top of the
mountains right down the other side
carrying about 60 70 pounds it's fast
fast
and anyway so you do you do the fan
dancing boy yeah at the end of that 80
80 people had gone
you know so the course is almost chopped
in off already
and then again day by day week by week
the course gets cut down and down and
down and down and that lucky number
again for me at the end of selection
which is six months there's seven of us
left
and so I'll look a number again and uh
yeah it's it's horrendous you know
there's a number of phases to it the
first phase is over the mountains and
it's like I said day two uh we lose 80
people and then every day the marches
for a month get longer
harder at night as well and you're on
your own navigating and moving out of I
won't say what speed because I can't
that's a freaking good speed and there's
no let up it's Relentless and is it are
they when when people are dropping out
is that because they're not successfully
passing the tasks or is that because
they're just going I can't carry on
there's a bit of both a lot of it is
mind it comes down to mind you know you
talk yourself out of it and you think oh
I'm never going to make this now
especially you're allowed to get what
they call a red or you did back then you
could you could mess up on one you had
to finish every Mark yeah but you could
be like 10 seconds over on one March 20
seconds maybe a minute and they go okay
that's a red next if you do that again
that's it you're done
um and most people just don't you know
they just go over the time were there
any points where you were like like if
yeah I had a few dramas like everybody
else you know and and I will say this
and it's true is when you do selection
you've got to be on top of your game
you've got to be fit you got to be able
to navigate
but there is an element of luck as well
you will get injured at some stage as a
fact I had a few issues you know
crossing the river one day in the mist
and it was horrendous I slipped in I
slipped on a rock Bergen on top of my
nearly drowned dropped my weapon I was
in the water for about 10 minutes
freezing cold minus 10 or whatever oh my
God trying to find my weapon which as a
Slip release and with the current moving
so fast it had moved so I'm going down
the river found it and I think that day
actually was my fastest time on that
March because I just didn't stop running
so if you turned up without the right oh
my God is that you are dropping over
left the Army I've never even gone back
to the party right yeah I mean it's
horrific right I was literally going
across the river I'd only left the
vehicle 20 meters and the mister was
right down and the option was looked at
my map I either go 800 meters down there
there's a little bridge over and then
come back to go in the direction I'm
crossing that River
bad mistake quarter of the way into the
river slippery rocks it's about
knee-deep and the power of the river
slipped head went over the Bergen came
on top of my head I'm almost drowning
so in the Panic of trying to stand up
I'll release a weapon and now the
current's taking it like yeah only 10
meters but you're trying to leave my
head I'm thinking yeah I'm thinking back
I've got to go back to the truck and
stuff like lost my what happened which I
didn't lose I dropped out now then I got
it but as soon as I got into the other
bank I was absolutely Frozen and I just
got my bear bearing and just sprinted
sprinted sprinted I think I've got the
fastest time that day on that but I mean
I needed it yeah I couldn't wait to get
to the end and get into some dry claws
it was horrific yeah so there's an
element to look and then I think on the
last March you do over that month my
knee was almost the size of my waist and
I was taking painkillers and I just
thought I'm gonna drag it with me and I
did that was a time if I was not going
to do it was I couldn't do it or your
knee yeah my knee I twisted my knee it
was all swollen up for the last two
marches it was Agony and I just took
painkillers and just went
and the last March was about 18 18 hours
it was a roof and do they see that
you're in this pain but yeah well it's
up to him yeah it's you to say that's it
done right unless it's unless you're
[__] arms hanging off or something
obviously medically no you're not going
on so that was the first phase yeah
that's the first phase which everybody
thinks that's a phase if you can get
through the mountains brilliant not at
all
phase the real phase of selection is the
jungle right it's horrendous now I'd
been to the Jungle three times before
I'd gone on selection because I joined
when I joined the parish original went
there and I went to two other jungles
since on training with the parachute
regiment so I went with a full sense of
security thinking well I'm good in the
jungle I love it now I'm happy with it
and
was I mistaken Jesus Christ and there's
nothing special about the soldiering
work you do in the jungle it's just
Relentless of being watched all the time
under pressure mental and physical
pressure what people don't realize is
the jungle in in Brunei where you do it
it's like being the Bracken Beacon
mountains but with trees on top of it
right so under that canopy you're going
up and you're going down and it's the
horrendous eat all the time it's 100
humidity it's just soaking wet you know
you're carrying a lot of weight you're
being scrutinized the staff don't
shelter you they ask you to do things
and you make a mistake and you're kind
of look at them thinking you're the same
taking notes right and it plays on your
mind you know and then you've got the
creatures you covered in leeches you've
got sores it's horrendous and you've got
that now for five weeks
I I'm gonna come back to the same
question but that yeah
that desire to do it yeah I mean I I
appreciate that it's probably not an
easy thing to articulate to someone like
me who just wouldn't be able to if I had
to do it maybe but the the knowledge
that I could just go do you know what
I'm just going to go back to what I was
already good at before in the parachute
regiment
that's the easiest bit that's why people
fail
because it's all about self-motivation
if expecting someone to grab you by the
arm and go no no don't give a drag you
forward it doesn't happen it's down to
you on selection because your work after
that when you be on the Enemy Lines
there's nobody dragging you forward
you're on your phone and that's who
they're looking for right okay sure but
for me my desire was I actually thrived
on it I did I really loved it and seen
people
Falling by the way so just give me more
strength again thinking I can keep going
I can keep going for this you know I'm
trying to encourage people to do with
you in our little groups and that you
know you try but you see their
weaknesses and it just gave me strength
to keep going so when you're in those
processes are you are you all banded
together and we can do this together or
are you going I've got to get through
this whatever you guys do no I mean the
first phase is individual it's over to
you all those navigation things and
those carrying the weight of them is
individual you're on your own it's it's
me versus everybody when you get to the
Jungle then you're into patrols then
it's teamwork looking after each other
but looking after yourself you know
you've gotta you've still gotta make
sure you're 100 then you can give 100
with the patrol so it's that as well so
they're looking at everything they're
looking at you again still isn't it
we're more of what are you like under
pressure working with anybody else and
that sort of stuff so so because yeah
because obviously they want you but they
want to know that you were somebody that
can be a team player I guess yeah so if
you're if you're too set off on around
and not interested in anyone else no
it's ain't gonna work see it's a
delicate balance then it is it and and I
know exactly how it works because I went
back as a DS yeah directing stuff years
later so I knew exactly at the time I
was on selection it's kind of all all
man for yourself but teamwork when you
needs to be teamwork you know what I
mean you've got to know when to turn
around turn it off and but then when you
go back as a DS I know exalia works and
what they're looking at is you they're
just looking at every single person as
who are you we don't care how big you
are how fit you are what you look like
what you've had in the past
stripping you back to the raw you and
putting you through physical mental
emotional pressures like you've never
been through to see how you cope can you
think outside the box can you come up
with a plan and an idea will you keep
going will you try and find a solution
or an excuse as soon as you're looking
for excuses
done you're done wow I know you're not
used to us well when you say there about
the the mental and the uh the mental the
mental journey and the mental fortitude
because one of the really I think famous
things about the SAS which I don't think
load is known about it but it's the
third phase which is am I right in
thinking because that's the
interrogation and can you tell us a
little bit about that yeah the
interrogation is it represents
you're gonna remember what our work is
we do work in small numbers you do work
individually you are very vulnerable you
ain't got all the support around you
immediately you know you're behind the
Enemy Lines you're in the enemies Back
Garden that's where you're working that
strategic level of working you know and
it's dangerous scary
um
so you've got to be able just to stand
on your own two feet now the biggest
vulnerability of being out there on your
own even in a small number you're always
outnumbered
if it goes wrong it's going to go wrong
big style and the worst case you can end
up in is being captured
not being killed being killed it's done
it's over and done but being captured
so what they do there's a phase that
sort of tries to prepare you for that
of how to survive under captivity how to
escape captivity and being evade you
know so that phase escaping invasion is
what you're talking about so we'll all
start with learning how to survive and
live off the land worst case and I've
been on your own how to navigate from
the stars from nature
all those raw skills that you need to
know because inevitably when it does go
tits up you know you probably ain't
gonna have the Live support you had with
you your burgundy may have lost or you
know you've had to run without it your
equipment so you're literally raw as it
can be
so you do you get to all those skills
and how to survive and all that sort of
stuff
and you've already done quite a bit of
it through the phase but then the really
intensify it and at the end of it you
know you go through a phase of learning
how to
if captured how to represent yourself to
give yourself a chance of living
building a rapport with the Enemy enough
to keep yourself one to find out a way
of escaping or to open that the Jedis
are going to come through the window at
some stage and save you so you're trying
to prolong your life by building a
rapport with these people so that phase
is where you get interrogated stress
positions and it is horrific it's
horrible
however you know everybody has a
different experience we're all different
inside the mind again for me
I want to say Enjoy I didn't enjoy it it
was horrific but I just knew they ain't
gonna kill me okay you ain't gonna kill
me but when you say it's horrific what
does that look like oh man
I mean I won't say how many hours it is
that you do it because they're not
allowed to but it's a hell of a lot more
than what you see on any TV program it's
a stress position yeah you're in these
stress positions I mean if I ask you now
just to
stand up straight then bend your knees
as half squat with your arms in the air
yeah after about two minutes you're
gonna you be like this trembling
so you like that you know and you're
there for hours
for hours and then you know that you've
got a guard Force that's got total
control of your life so that's really
messing with your mind you can't piss
you can't talk you can't move
somebody else to control your life you
just think about it it's horrible and
then you've been putting these
horrendous positions like your backs
killing you think your back's gonna snap
your shoulders are hanging off your arms
are hanging off just holding your head
up
it's just the worst of everything you
want to die you're like well you're
actually praying to be interrogated
because at least when you're getting
Dragged In and being screamed and
shouted alone mentally your arms and
your backs in a better position for a
bit and then by the time they're
screaming shouting at you and dissecting
you and then you feel your mind started
to struggle you're hoping to go back for
a stress position so you're bouncing
between but it's a long long process and
a lot a lot of people do feel that but
everyone is different again for me
I thought you ain't gonna written
someone else out yeah reality of the
world
in reality this is gonna this is gonna
be a lot worse than what I'm getting
here but that processor when we do it
you just get I know you just keep saying
something this is just a game but you
start hallucinating bearing in mind
before you get captured anyway you've
been on the run for yeah two weeks you
you know you sleep deprivation food
deprivation you're absolutely exhausted
and then you've got somebody just
dragging you around
who's just got total can you know don't
not even being able to get for a piss
yeah it's not like you see on the TV you
put your hand up and ask for a person
that ain't gonna happen no I'm gonna
[__] clap around the head but then
like you say it's what's preparing you
for is a reality yeah it'd be a lot
worse if it was ever yeah you're
preparing yourself you get an Insight an
idea of what it's going to be like when
you are working I know and and you so
seven of you yeah past yeah which is I
don't know what that is as a percentage
down from 283 but yeah I mean they all
say that the regiments the one percent
of the one percent they want to do it
you know so and then once you get in to
the SAS yeah
how different was it in terms of
workings from the parachute regiment
I love that you asked me this and I have
told this a lot if you've heard it I'm
sorry but
so when I joined the SAS right
um you have this expectation what's
going to be like yeah of course a couple
of friends have gone before me I don't
know what they're like they're really
fair they're strong they're big guys
doing great stuff so when you get to the
end of selection in my head I'm thinking
right
these are going to be super fit super
crazy people
if I said to you guys here now I'm going
to bring you five SES guys most people
be thinking okay big fit v-shape but you
know
that's kind of what you get you just
think that image I don't know why
everybody does I even I did it so when I
got to the end of selection I got to all
right and there's no big celebration
there's no parade there's no nothing
else just there you know the regiment
Soul major comes in the command office
goes okay well done you've all got there
and did it there's your battery there's
your belt you're going to be scoring
you're going to do scoring you're going
to Mountain true a squad whatever it is
you're like
great you don't care actually you don't
want to Pray by the time you're just
glad to be alive and be the [__] end
of it yeah so off you go and I go across
the B Squadron
um which are the guys who did the
embassy years ago oh yes would you ever
heard about great Squadron not all great
squadrons but B's Better B is better so
you got a B Squad I got a B Squadron and
they're all in these they're on little
sort of
um areas we call them interest room uh
where everybody hangs out and that's
where you sort of you know you'll meet
you out every morning decide what we're
doing we're training we're doing what
operations are going on all that sort of
stuff and then
and so it is so I get sent to B Squadron
Mountain Troop
so I've got my burial got my bell
feeling proud you know off I go walking
to B Squad and interest room and as I
walk in I'm like
am I in the wrong places
I thought I walked into a council office
in Hereford right I'm like what do you
mean it's like fat block over there bald
headed block over there skinny bloke
over there already got any teeth
I was like
this is the SAS in my head I'm thinking
um are you kidding me
because these people misshaped all
sources I'm thinking what the [__] Josh
joined
so I'm a little bit bewildered to be
honest I mean I was quite fit I was
skinny but I would because I just come
through selection but I thought what is
this there are some really fit dudes
there of course there's all these
different shaper people and there's a
big guy
another thing I can call in fact big
fact I'll make it a cup of tea and he
sees me like looking in shock and he
turns around he's making a cup of tea
and he looks old with me goes you're
right son yeah I'm all right you and he
goes yep
you want to go for a run I thought Hey
fat guy's asking me to go for a run but
yeah
I can [__] run
mate we went out the gate right
I saw the soul of his [__] boot for
about 30 meters I never seen him again
so I get back to the interest room and
he's already had a shower and doing and
I'm like what the [__] is this
and then the penny dropped this ain't
about our image this is about what is
there and that's why I remember on
selection certain people passing certain
people not passing and thinking it
really is about what these people have
got in there and then day two or three I
haven't been there long and operation
comes in a job
these bloke walks in with a role in he's
smoking and rolling flicking on and I
thought he's the guy going to clean the
bins major
and he was right issues there's a
operation going down you know it needs
to be in a place save these people's
lives whatever it was and he's gone
let's do it and I thought it was a joke
I'm like looking around going what the
[__] is going on
and then I watched these people put this
plan together all sat around
no you know just talking and the next
thing you're off bang doing this
operation
and he was like Wow are they bringing
you in at this point yeah yeah yes I
mean yeah and the Soul major is like
sorry what's your name someone when
Billy went all right welcome Billy how
we're going to do this right asking me
and I'm like
I've just turned up well you know but
that's how they are yeah and they expect
you to have something to say there's no
rank there's no class it's you know
there is run we all know is in charge
they don't wear the rant we know that
guy's a the main man in ease this and
now he's the patrol command and he's a
troop staffy and does it still have the
hierarchy in like the way yeah he does
it he does but to be honest the the
operational side of it is run by the
guys the officers generally the younger
officers get involved because they're
new as well they're still they're
learning and they get fed into it the
older officers they all season
thereafter they're the ones who do all
the planning the government planning at
the embassies around the Globes and that
side of it so all the groundwork really
is done by the blogs so from Sergeant
made down is where it really happens
and yeah and just it was just so I was
like oh so elves in this all new world
albums up to me
I think for the first eight months other
than one or two times
I didn't even wear a uniform right grown
man I was in places around the globe I'd
never even heard of
you know I was learning a language I
didn't even know existed
and then next week speaking in this
foreign country doing
surveillance type stuff and whatever so
once he joined the SAS obviously you're
in like an amazing physical and mental
yeah position
but were there any per were there any
points where you were like I think
I think I'm good like were there any
points where you felt close to death
any that you can talk about I know a lot
of stuff you can
every day right sure wait is that how is
that how intense it is the way you train
yeah you are you know you've side by
side Realms going past your ears to the
in the dark respirators on you've thrown
yourself out in a aircraft at ridiculous
eyes you know through the night with all
this equipment into the ocean you're
constantly training
real realistic dangerous training we do
lose unfortunate people in training and
people badly injured and then
operational yeah freaking hell you know
from
the Bosnia days to Afghan to Iraq
close to even being shot or blown up or
both
regular regular you know and like I say
because you just get on with it you just
kind of get on with it and it's funny
because
when the blogs get together
you'll have a beer and they'll go look
at each other and go how the [__] did
you walk out of that and it'll be a
certain operation where somebody's
nearly blowing your head off or had the
drop on you but somehow you got out of
it or a particular bombs gone off quite
closer but it's all been impacted by a
vehicle in front of you or whatever it
is so there's all these crazy stories
that you get involved in and
yeah it's at times when you get a bit
you forget about most of it but a lot of
it I say you forget about most what you
do
there'll always be something that'll
trigger yeah in my own mind of I
remember that time
you know and I'll give you one example
which I don't mind talking about was and
we're in Bosnia and um real weird
situation actually and it wasn't well I
guess it was
it was dangerous it was dangerous of
course it was and we had an interpreter
there's only two of us and we're on the
ground
and we're trying to find our way through
to the front line because out there it
was a mess you know you added serbs
croats and Muslims all fighting each
other yes and then in between all that
was minefields everywhere we were trying
to figure out exactly what it was
fighting knew when the next thing was
going to happen all this sort of stuff
and we had there was two of us and we
had an interpreter with us and The
Interpreter was a female
local so she came with she was balls he
was a wonderful wonderful girl
absolutely Nails we're obviously
sneaking around nobody knows who we are
what we're doing
we end up trying to find where this
front line was where the main fight was
taking place this particular time we end
up in this friggin Minefield and we
didn't know we're in until we're halfway
through it so we're now lying amongst
all these mines
so now we've got a
either get out as best we can without
going blowing up or continue with the
task to do what we want to do and then
get out so we decide we're going to
continue with the task and we'll get
through
and we end up overlooking this Village
and this Village is getting smashed and
it's like a film set houses on fire
there's gunfighters people fighting the
street there's people hanging out in
cars dead there's bodies everywhere and
we're watching it from across this
position you know probably about 800
meters from it The Interpreter is with
us
and she was wonderful she was used to
all this it's her area it's her country
and she had a little transistor radio
so me and my buddy are watching this
trying to make sure we don't get blown
up and watching reporting what's going
down and trying to do what we need to do
and she says okay I'll play the radio
and we're like well the bombs and
bullets going off right No One's Gonna
know who we are so she I said yeah no
problem so she puts a little radio on
and she's behind us
and we're watching what's going on Hotel
California comes on the song
and I can either something you're kind
of seeing it in your head as you're
watching this horrific thing happening
in front of you
and then my mate nudges me
and I was like well it goes behind you
so look at our interpreter as I look
Almost sure that she's in floods of
Tears
and in my tiny stupid head I think oh
that record obviously reminds her of a
boyfriend or something so I'll turn
around to and I said a name I says hey
If It's upsetting you just turn it off
and she went no Billy
that's my house
I was like I just wanted to roll over
onto a mine and just end it I thought oh
my God you know
it was just horrific but trying to paint
that scene what I'm talking about and
literally it was her house getting
smashed on Fires people screaming
I just and you're in those situations
all the time so we carry on doing what
we're doing and quickly get out but my
point of saying that was there's certain
things they'll trigger certain things
and that song just reminded me of it you
know or a smell or remind me of a
certain situation in another country
where
where so-and-so was killed or that
happened or this happened yeah there's
things that you I mean that's sort of an
amazing story like just but but it
reinforces like the stuff that you do
like the stuff that all people in the
military do but then when you're saying
the one percent of the one percent
there's things that you guys do that
like
civilians just wouldn't be able to
process how it feels to do it no how do
you get to the point where you come like
can you process these things
indefinitely Or do they start leaving at
all like when you talk when you're you
know
doing operations that will probably end
other people's lives that's something
most humans never do most humans never
take a life and a lot of humans have a
very limited exposure to death as well
yeah
people like yourself will have a high
amount of exposure is there a way of
protecting yourself against that or is
it are you on a sort of countdown to it
starting to having a no I think
we kind of alluded to it earlier every
single person is different everybody's
mind's different you know we talk about
comments about I sometimes can't get my
head around out people
give up on the interrogation so quick
and all that stuff but we're all
different
so tolerating not tolerating but dealing
with what we do deal with death
destruction
almost losing your own life or losing
your mates life you might lose his life
next to you
you go through a massive process in your
own mind of feeling guilty
could have done this should have done
that would they have helped
you blame yourself you feel
um like you've let yourself down and you
know so you go through all these
emotions and whatever it might be in the
situations and you always ask yourself
one thing is could I have done a better
job
the truth is probably not
and the other thing is it's already
happened so you've just got a sort of
process it
and move forward from it now the way I
I've never had
a mental problem I'm just lucky or
fortunate not to have had any issues
with it like I say I have my moments I
have my dark times but I just sort of
I don't know I just get on with it now
will I be the same in five years time
ten years time I don't know there might
be something that triggers something
that I can't handle anymore
but right now
I think by talking a little bit about it
and especially talking with the people
that we should be talking peers who know
what I'm talking about because it's like
anything as well you know
and um while on this subject especially
with the military
I don't think we used to handle it very
well people that had been we'd had some
bad situations at times you know
and would you just come back and just be
expected just to
go home for a couple of days and then
back into work and off you go again
there's no decompression or nothing and
I think that's stem to a lot of the
problems that we're having today so
you're in a kind of in a hunting state
of reflection and processing like little
enough and we're just yeah yeah a little
and often yeah you know have you got
your remembrance days
so especially today social media there's
always every other day somebody will put
you know God bless us I would rest in
peace I did anything I remember I was
but then there's the other sides of it
that we've walked away from where we've
all walked away from it's kind of funny
but there are times I've got hell I've
had chills in my back and how the hell
did that happen how did I just walk away
from that somebody your distance from me
trying to blow my head off a mist
with Six Bullets has that happened yeah
God and I'm like how the [__] is that
I'm gonna do this day I still don't know
Stevie Wonder could have done it
[Music]
yeah you know you just yeah and it's
well looking and like I've always said
it shouldn't have happened and it didn't
happen you know and Blossom said to me
how the F did you walk away from that
well then when somebody puts about Six
Bullets between your net your net your
chin let you down that line there and
where your arms are where your weapon
was but and didn't kill me
he didn't get a second chance that's for
sure
yeah but I mean that's those sort of
scenarios you know you go you really
live them and you go
bonkers
you know yeah I mean it makes it
certainly I'm dropping that side of the
car
and the whole you know obviously in that
Ali G thing where he stood against the
wall and they open up on him and it goes
all yeah yeah yeah and then he's
obviously yeah yeah you know we've had a
situation like that
mortar bomb has landed that side of the
car and it's hit it and the whole thing
is all around like what the [__]
God you're like yeah
let's go
so I mean but basically Billy you're
someone that like you've got so many
aspects to your life so it's like you'd
you'd want you'd I think we need four
hours five hours I know that one of the
things that we want to get on to is the
celebrity bodyguard stuff yeah and so I
guess because that's a fascinating thing
because I guess that's not something a
lot of people do is it when they leave
the military
alarm as you do get into security
um not a lot of them do it at that level
yeah you know I was I was just fortunate
to be
in a place to be asked to go and do it
at that level right from the moment I
stepped out the Army to be honest but
Brad Pitt and Angelina yeah because
they're like two of the biggest apples
on the tree in terms of well they were
on the in the day when I when I did that
job there were I mean
prior to leaving the military you know I
I also I did 27 years I did more than 27
years because you do I stayed on a thing
called
um well the reserves I did five years of
Reserve I didn't really do anything at
all so I never really count that anyway
okay but in all that time when I left
I had it I had to find a job
and the hardest thing about that was
well firstly finding a job but secondly
you know you spent I had spent all my
life
denying who it was and where I was
because that's what we do we have to you
know we're not even on
any registers anyway or anything so
that's our lifestyle so we've and then
all of a sudden
that career is over you got to go to
work so what do you do
and then I'll get off at a job security
and it was for Brad and Angelina
at the time with the biggest A-list on
the planet and it's good pay I needed
work and I thought well
I'm going to take the job so I took the
job and it was really awkward
because all of a sudden well you know
I've come from nobody knows where the
hell I am to all these like this cameras
everywhere and people who's this new
blog who's that you know he was really
uncomfortable I was kind of one foot in
the water one foot out the water am I
doing it am I not doing it and it was
just
he was awful being shot out with a
camera as opposed to a gun was worse
than ever is it not hard to come out of
something like the military and then if
you're bodyguarding people like that is
it not hard to even have a conversation
with people like that because if they're
going to and going oh can you get the
vegan food in and you're are you not
going do you get what I mean like no I
understand exactly and that's a good
point Ben actually because I was going
to allude to that so the first you know
firstly stepping out into these new
world cameras everywhere in the
Limelight on every magazine that's going
and I mean and then down to yeah can you
make sure my stuff's at the dry cleaners
but yeah and the driver's got the you
know like you know
yeah but you soon adapt you soon go you
know what and he actually I started to
chuckle about that can you make sure the
Sushi's gone California rolls and I'm
like
do it yourself
but you do you kind of you get used to
and you start to enjoy it it's about
to be fair all the skill sets that I had
in the military
it's a you've got all the skills that
you need outside you just got to tone it
down and adapt it to what it really is
he's finding out what it really is you
know and as soon as I realized once I'd
stop worrying about me being caught on
camera and me doing this I'm really
concentrating on the job and what is the
job the job really
is protecting an image that's all you're
really doing you know 90 of it of course
you've got to be physically there you've
got to be aware of
lunatics who might want to have a go at
them or want to you know kidnap or
whatever you've got to have that in your
mind
whereas the life before it was all about
that that was a priority deaf kidnapping
killing whatever it is now it's making
sure they're not still in front of a
camera with coffee down there white
shirt or
say the wrong thing when they're drunk
you know that so it was adapting that to
babysitting really it's like glorified
babysitting and it is a Threat Level
there is it present it's a threat level
you know everybody wants 15 minutes of
fame yeah I mean look at John Lennon
yeah yeah somebody will have a pop
whenever you know I remember Tom Cruise
who I'd looked after Tom a while but and
and
it was after I looked up and thank God
he was walking the red carpet somebody
pulled a pistol on him he was a water
pistol right
you know and fired water into his face
that could have been acid so if people
so there is a threat there there are
they're not around every corner but you
have to have that in your mind
yeah don't get complacent but yeah there
is a threat there and you you did quite
a few of the big names yeah I did yeah I
um
I did a lot of Moonlighting if I'm
honest I looked after all Colgan which I
[__] loved oh goodness wow I looked
after all organ for a little character
just for two nights I think it was but
it was funny yeah and the thing about
that was he's looking at me I'm looking
at him he's like twice the size of me
and he said he's thinking this blog's
either oh there's Nails all mad
he doesn't know and I'm playing it cool
like hey me want to test it and he's
like no so it's all about confidence
yeah so I looked after him I looked
after
um Kate Moss briefly I looked after
um Russell Crowe quite a bit actually
Russell's awesome
um Tom Cruise
one night and Ellie's wife
um so Michael Kane fantastic actually he
was the last guy I looked after Michael
he's brilliant
a brand nanji yeah it's probably the
most famous kind of like celebrity
bodyguard film of recent years it was
like the taken film he starts off and
he's like oh Liam Neilson yeah yes and
is he is it important to build a rapport
with the people or yeah it's
oh you've got to see this new bodyguard
program it's the most realistic I
watched about 10 minutes away right
and it's just not real because of course
you've got other report you can't be all
robotic with the curly piece hanging out
you're a stood there like a robot you
need to know I need to know exactly
everything from my clients underwear
sizes to their medical records to what
they're like what they don't like you
know because if they're having a pissed
off day you're having a pissed off day
and you've got to be able to speak with
each other and and be flexible and I've
got to be able to read your moods you
can't do that if you're walking around
like a freaking robot and trying too
busy looking like sculptured polystyrene
you know big arms and all the rest of it
but you got to be on a level where you
can speak with them and you've got to be
able to speak bluntly with them as well
you know I would every one of my clients
advice is we ain't doing that oh really
doing it yeah so you have to be able to
oh yeah you're right okay yeah of course
because otherwise you put yourself in a
position that you for instance as an
example you know if my clients want to
go to a particular venue there's a
massive over excellus crowd which they
do get obvious I.E the security ain't in
place there's normally security at these
venues if it ain't in place and it it's
it's going to spill over and go wild I'm
going to control it I can't control 30
40 50 people
and the client would go well we really
need to go oh you ain't going right find
an alternative
yeah and that was the beauty with when I
was doing we had a great Mutual
understanding I'm here to provide
security that's what you pay me for
we're not best mates I am your friend I
am in May but I've got a job to do I'll
only get it wrong once then I'll look a
right Pratt you know and you're probably
gonna end up in a bad position yeah so
you you gotta allow me and listen to me
when I say what I want to do you tell me
what you want to do and I'll find an
alternative if I can if I can't that's
the way security comes first and I that
was me with every single one of them as
I'm speaking to you is how I spoke to
all my clients you know and they ought
to be disrespectful I'm doing a job I
don't
I've you know I mean into this you're a
celebrity so what you're the person
who's paying my wages and if I if I
ain't working with you I don't get a
wage it's as simple as that and did you
develop any friendships or is it more
all right great friendship with all of
them I'd have a drink with them I've
laughed stupid message of around and all
that sorts of but then there's a line
yeah of course when I'm working I'm
working you know and yeah and even in
the time off you feel you know we'd be
in their house having a couple of beers
I'm gonna laugh and joke I'd still make
sure that everyone outside was Secure
yeah you can never let your hair down in
the thing about that bodyguarding world
is people think it's glamorous yeah we I
got paid well yeah I've traveled a lot
yeah I met these cool people if that's
what you're into but I was working 18
hours a day yeah and they go to bed I've
got two hours work to be done you
couldn't trust the drivers couldn't
trust anybody else everybody just wants
to steal your job because the driver's
all of a sudden turn into
Sterling mosstroke evasive driving
instructors whenever they get in the car
because they're trying to impress right
okay well they turn up stinking of beer
or something else or they're you know
they're too busy instead of driving you
know my clients in the back they'll talk
and they're like
right here right
and trust him and I used to catch him
out all the time you know a lot of the
drivers would say okay tomorrow morning
we're going to go down to Smith's make
sure you're there on time do a wreck he
did it yeah no problem nothing for well
I ain't going there jump in the car go
to turn right at the gate that morning
I've got another turn left but you say
we're going to Smith's no we're not
we're going to Dailies
and I'll go send the next drive go down
to Smith's tell me what you see drive
down to Smith's oh all the paparazzi are
there oh really really you just you
couldn't trust anybody mate so you had
to constantly having to be one step
ahead of the curve to just to get the
day's job done you know because if it
all if they turn up is where they're
trying to keep a little profile and have
a easy light and then there's Paparazzi
every
they can't be who they really are
they've got to have this image along we
all have any enemies like we do for
Instagram or whatever it is you've got
to be this person they can't be this off
and it ruins a day then it ruins your
day so
you've just gotta you know stay on top
of all that and how How does it go from
that so am I right in thinking you've
got an MBA yeah don't you okay so
because I I think that you correct me if
I'm wrong we'll edit it out but I think
that you were the most decorated officer
on the TV show yeah
they love their tiles and they they put
up the most decorated yeah SAS eyes
ranking on TV I'm not the most
decorating no no from the show from the
show yeah yeah I mean my experience if
you pull those guys together I've got
more experience than every single one of
them put together right not to say
they're not good they're good at what
they do but I just had a longest survey
time I was fortunate I think I've been
in every conflict other than Falklands
so how does it come about that you get a
call asking if you want to be in a TV
show about the SAS it's funny as well
but I got asked to be honest when I
started working with the brand names I
got asked all the time right the TV work
yeah for TV will you do this will you do
that I was never interested I was busy
anyway I couldn't have done it then as
I'll start to step off the gas with that
I got asked
like a real funny phone call
through a friend of mine saying oh the
this guy these guys running a TV show I
want to speak to you so I said oh I'll
speak to him I said look we got your
name we're running this program where
we're going to take
fittest Eight British people or nine
fitted people from the UK to the Jungle
we rang the jungle School in Belize and
the guy in charge there was a guy I took
through his course right and he spoke to
him and said look we're looking for a
jungle instructor dirty girls who it was
really good in the jungle but he's
horrible he goes I know just
they show he sells it to me so he goes
yeah on a real horrible
but he's really good in the jungle so
that so it made me laugh and I was hang
on mate
back back and forth and they wanted to
run this program and I said hang on what
do you want to do and they said we want
to do this put them through the paces
they said fittest people in the UK I
said stop let me tell you something it
doesn't matter who they are they go to
the Jungle they're going to die ain't
gonna work no no you don't understand I
mean no no you don't step back and forth
anyway I did this program called
unbreakable I don't know if you ever
heard of it no it was on
I think it was channel five Ricochet was
a company a great great but she was
great people and the students were
fantastic but they'd never been to the
Jungle the jungle's deadly it doesn't
matter I don't care who fit or strong
you think you are so anyway these people
will turn up at the jungle we're going
to do this course and I've already worn
them 40 minutes into it I've broke all
of them
he's just
they underestimate yeah yeah so I've now
almost got the producer on the neck and
got [__] told her this so for the
next three days I'm teaching them and
then we do 30 minutes of running them
ragged so make this program and he put
me off I mean I ain't doing this no more
don't [__] listen and then I left a
few years and years and years and then
SES who does wins came around and one of
the guys on the original Colin
McLaughlin we've Ann and Foxy and Ollie
Rings remember says mate we're putting
this program together SS will you come
on it and as soon as I said I said I
said no because they've been cheesy
little things about it and I said no I
don't I don't want to do not interested
mate anyway that went out at the same
time again asked to do it a program
called
SFI Tough Enough and then in between all
that
sas1 going out and two about to
do series two I'll get the call from a
producer from minnow and he hounded me
saying will you come on the show and I
wouldn't know and he goes I said look
where are you so I'm in London I said
mate I ain't coming to London anyway he
says I'll come to Hereford and he
literally after off the phone jumped in
his car drove to Marathon so we sat and
talked about the show what it's all
about and I said okay that's when I
joined it
and it was a bit uncomfortable to start
with not I mean the lads there were
three SBS guys obviously on the SAS guy
at the time
um although I had a lot lot more
experience I didn't want to be anything
more than just in the background anyway
dear so I was not I was in any threat to
ant or anybody else
and it was all right I enjoyed you know
doing bits and pieces and
took a little while to get used to what
what it was really all about and the
mirror rooms when we were doing that the
mirror rooms when we did the interviews
I didn't really like it I didn't really
understand it but now I love it it's
what it's all about so it took a while
to get used to but then I stayed with it
and stayed with it and then moving on to
where we are now I'm now the chief
instructor on it and you so you enjoy
the show do you like doing it I love it
mate yeah I love it gives me a chance to
keep fit yeah it's like being back in
the military there's no script there's
no uh rehearsals there's no retakes
right it's yeah it's a basically we run
it as a course right the celebrity thing
is brilliant because you know every
celebrity's got a fan base you know
people worship these people wherever the
wherever they come from whatever they're
doing whether the soccer's players or TV
people or whatever it is
and the fact that again we don't know
what's going to come out their mouth
when they come out with something
whether they've been abused all this you
know towards you like whoa okay okay and
weren't expecting that
and they walk out of that room six
inches taller because they've got it off
the shoulders we give them sort of okay
done no sympathy let's move forward and
as soon as you tell them that they're
like whoa I don't have to be a victim
anymore
but the beauty of that is
there'll be 40 50 000 people I've
watched that show that night I'll tell
you now start messaging them if he can
talk about it she can talk yeah yeah I
can 100 and we get amazing messages
honestly unbelievable you know and I
love that feeling of knowing
it's not just about thrashing people
it's not a mud run it's not a Spartan
challenge
and it's not rehearsed so we run it as a
course and as we would anybody in the
military you've stepped into our world
you've volunteered yeah you're gonna get
screamed at and the only reason you're
Scream and Shout out and which is
different to the real SES we've only got
10 days to put yeah for everything so
you've got to get it going and motivate
them and put them under pressure are
there any are there any celebrities
that have been through the course that
you think could have potentially done
the real course no
don't be so ridiculous yeah there's not
nobody on any of it I thought
no dude these are 10 14 days yeah
sasolation is freaking six no sure but
like there's that side of and also not
to be disrespectful to anybody
you've got to be in the military to go
into yes yes that's the reality of it
you know so what they do is amazing you
know and these people that come on this
course for the show
they're doing 18 hours a day you don't
you only get 40 minutes if you're on the
show they get put for their Paces so
it's a it's a big big it's probably the
biggest test they'll do in their life
you people look a good well
you've got you know Fatima Woodbridge 60
years old you've got
all these athletes how's she going to
compete with them well she isn't Fatima
Whitbread is competing with Fatima with
bread yeah
the Sprinter is who will look at every
single one of you and go when you're 100
angular the same as this is or 100 so
every day we have these prayers and we
push you we want Fatima to run two
kilometers with a Bergen I want him to
run five kilometers in a bit faster
because that's when he's being tested
and you're being tested think you know
because no matter what situation you are
in there's a way out there's no I'm
gonna say a way out there's an option
and I've been in some places where I got
me we're dead we ain't going out of this
and then when you go I've got to do
something I'm going to find an option
you find an option it's never a good one
but we're perseverance and a little bit
of hard work around it you get through
it and that's what you're looking for in
every single person and that's what you
get out of these people
when you look back you know you you
started off as someone who had like you
know it could have been that boxing was
your what you were going to do and then
it was parachute regiment yeah and it
was SAS then celebrity bodyguarding and
then TV work you know they're kind of
yeah roots that a lot of people would
have as their one thing that they went
into
when you look back at that kind of very
varied life yeah like what what do you
think it's taught you overall like
what's something you've learned across
all your experiences honestly honestly
I've made to to be grateful and to
realize how fortunate we are and also to
realize there's always somebody worse
off than you seven percent of what I do
today is Charity giving back I'm not
saying this thing oh you know great
that's what I do you know putting kids
through school because I've been I've
been lucky and I've been privileged to
be where I am I've I've put myself in
some of the most craziest hardest
positions you can imagine and some of
you know not through my fault and I've
gone through it and I like to give that
back to somebody the people who give me
an opportunity in life like I said the
old man it was stole from Fairly
influential man the guy who ran the
cadets another very influential money in
my life
Benny the guy got killed just give him
put him in the straight and narrow my
Corporal in Depot all these people that
gave me opportunities I wanted you know
all that experience and that knowledge
give it to somebody else pass it on to
other people the younger generation
basically well local Philly it's been uh
inspirational and fascinating chat I
mean and the other thing that I always
find interesting about people like
yourself is that you always start off
going like School wasn't for me school
wasn't for me I never got my school but
then you're able to talk so well about
all the different complicated
like situations and I sometimes wonder
with people like you whether you just
were at the wrong School
that's possible mate but I know I was a
little
thanks so much for coming in mate it's
been an absolute pleasure thanks man
cheers I enjoyed it cheers Philly cheers
I said to this day now I felt I've
killed someone I've killed someone I've
shot someone it was tap on the shoulder
going a good job mate [__] good job
and it took me a good week
to
get my mind in gear thinking that's my
job that's a job with a sniper